bonjour véronique le floch merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france ce matin pas d'accord à
bruxelles reprise des négociations en
juin donc on vient de l'apprendre
soulager ou inquiètent soulager plus en
fait les discussions ne sont pas
abouties trop de désaccord persistent à
la pac il faut savoir n'a jamais eu de
vrai bilan établi et aujourd'hui même si
les ambitions environnementales sont
ceux qui la guide toute l'ambition du
revenu du maintien de revenus aux
agriculteurs a été mise de côté
et si je regarde sur les années sur une
trentaine d'années depuis que cette
réforme de la pac à a été établi en
profondeur en monnaie constante on est
avec des prix a divisé par trois et si
justement les prix avaient suivi tous
ces objectifs environnementaux aurait pu
être établies et fixées et chaque
agriculteur aurait pu ce de façon
volontaire faire les choix est allé dans
ce sens là or nous avons choisi une
politique de prix mondiaux de façon
aller à l'export nous avons en parallèle
pas nous et nos politiques ont signé des
accords de libre échange et aujourd'hui
on est avec une politique dont les z qui
vont aux agriculteurs quelque part vont
directement aux industriels puisque se
disent retient en gros sur nos prix payé
l'équivalent de ces aides perçues par là
l'europe et
prends ce maître en réalité ces aides de
la pac
lorsque ces produits sont exportés aussi
donc la politique vous vous dénoncez la
mondialisation et vous appelez à plus de
protectionnisme à tout à fait et là tu
on a bien vu même dans les points qui
sont qui relève d août des ocm donc des
organisations communes de marché
c'est spécifique à chacune des
productions tous les points qui sont
importants et qui aurait pu être
discutée noms n'ont pas été abordés je
pense par exemple à à mettre fin à tout
ce qui est des importations en fait sur
les produits qui contiennent des résidus
de pesticides ou autres interdits en
europe ces points là sont cruciaux et à
partir du moment où on sera avec des
prises de décisions qui vont dans le
sens de la souveraineté alimentaire
européenne comme il peut le mettre en
avant
on pourra espérer quelque chose y ait
davantage quelque chose depuis
l'équitable on le voit sur les images à
côté de vous à côté de votre photo une
manifestation on l'a dit hier à paris
devant le siège de pôle emploi 200
personnes ont d'ailleurs été délogés
manu militari par les forces de l'ordre
on a même vu une élue insoumise
bénédicta taurine d'ailleurs être être
bousculé mais au bout du compte il ya
une entrevue qui a été obtenu avec le
conseiller agriculture d'emmanuel macron
est ce que vous êtes satisfait de cela
ou est-ce que vous êtes déçu parce que
ce n'est pas le président de la
république indique donc qu'elle fait pas
notre syndicat mais on partage quand
même tout ce qui est mis en avant c'est
à dire la pac qui contribuent ou qui
n'interrompt pas ce plan social
tout ça ce sont des raisons les
revendications légitimes
demain l'agriculture ne continuera à
exister que si nous sommes non voix à
produire parce que jusqu'à présent cette
politique agricole commune n'a favorisé
que l'agrandissement c'est aussi vrai
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de perspectives
de revenu et donc pas de de perspectives
palacio et c'est ce signal là qu'on
attend aujourd'hui pour que déjà les
cymbales
mais qu'est ce que alors que ce soit
vous à la coordination rurale ou bien la
confédération paysanne
qu'est-ce qu'il faut demander à apple
dell du car le conseiller agricole du
président ou bien au ministre de
l'agriculture 1
ou à emmanuel macron qu'est-ce qu'il
faut demander mais de manière très
concrète de façon concrète il faudrait
comme on le veut pour les produits
alimentaires de la transparence la
transparence par rapport à la
distribution des aides et j'entends par
là tous les gros montants qui sont un
distribués aux industriels pour leur
investissement à l'export les soutiens
pour le transport un des soutiens pour
même vis-à-vis des écoles vis-à-vis on a
besoin de dire aux consommateurs que
l'argent de la pac ne va pas qu aux
agriculteurs et demain ce sera peut-être
encore moins le cas puisque avec les
décors régime
un tout qui est environnemental on
voudrait presque nous conduire à des
certifications et qui nous conduiront à
payer des organismes pour nous offrir
ces certifications et qui perdirent
leurs étudiants sa part comme d'une
bonne intention alors elle est déjà
verte l'agriculture 1 avec toutes les
années avec les pertes de surface qui ne
sont plus cultivés
on sait qu'on est dans non dans une
phase qui n'est plus d'expansion mais au
contraire on est dans la récession
agricole merci véronique le floch
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes la vice
présidente de la coordination rurale